[موسيقى]
صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
فاجنر تقترب من مركز مدينه باكموت والجيش
الاوكراني يؤكد قدرته على الدفاع عن
المدينه
اتفاق فلسطيني اسرائيلي على الحد من العنف
والتحريض ووقف الاجراءات الاحاديه من
ثلاثه الى سته اشهر
بهدف تحقيق استقرار الاسواق بنك يو بي اس
يستحوذ على كريدي سويس مقابل ثلاثه
مليارات فرنك سويس
تهم قضائيه تلاحق الرئيس الامريكيه السابق
دونالد ترامب وتباين حول تاثيرها على
مصيره الانتخابي
[موسيقى]
وصلتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
لا تزال مدينه
الجيش الروسي للسيطره عليها ومقاومه
القوات الاوكرانيه المدعومه من الغرب في
اخر التطورات باتت قوات مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه على بعد كيلو متر واحد فقط من
مركز المدينه التي لم تسقط لحد الان
بالكامل في يد موسكو على الطرف الاخر لا
يزال الجيش الاوكراني مصمما على قدرته على
الصمود في وجه القوات الروسيه بهذا الخصوص
قلل المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش الاوكراني
سيرجي ان القوات الاوكرانيه خارج مدينه
بخت ما زالت قادره على وقف تقدم الوحدات
الروسيه بما يسمح بتسليم الذخيره والاغذيه
والمعدات والادويه للقوات التي تدافع عن
المدينه من الداخل حيث تتواصل معك
كيف ورغم تاكيد صمودها في ضخمه الا انها
لم تنفي الصعوبات التي تواجهها امام حده
الهجمات الروسيه وكان قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال قد اكد ان ضخمه لا
تزال بؤره الهجمات الروسيه مضيفا ان
القوات الروسيه تستخدم كل قواتها لاختراق
خطوط الدفاع الاوكرانيه ومحاصره المدينه
بالكامل وتعد مشاهدينا معركه باخمت اطول
المعارك منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث
اكتسبت اهميه كبيره لموسكو التي تحرص على
تحقيق انتصار هناك بعد اشهر من القتال
معي من واشنطن
مركز التحليل السياسي العسكري في معهد
هاتسون مرحبا بك معنا ريتشارد في اخبار
الساعه من العربيه هل تعتقد ان
الاوكرانيين ما تزال لديهم فرصه
لاستعاده باخمه والدفاع عنها امام هذا
الهجوم الروسي
بوسعه من يقوموا بذلك ولكن بطبيعه الحال
هم لا يرغبون ان يقعوا في الفخ
وبالتالي فان قيمه مخمور
هي ليست المدينه بحد ذاتها وانما هي تسمح
للجانبين بتدمير قواتهم وبالتالي
الاوكرانيون يمكن ان يقتلوا الكثير من
الجنود الروسي عندما يحاولون السيطره على
المدينه وهذا افضل لهم من الدفاع فهم
يرغبون في الحفاظ على
القوات اكثر من الحفاظ على الارض
نعم طيب ولكن سيد ريتشارد المعركه تبدو
انها لصالح الروس بشكل كبير جدا خاصه مع
دور قوات فاجنر هناك هل ما بعد معركه
باخموت ما هو ماذا سيكون بعد هذه المعركه
التي استمرت الان لاكثر من سته اشهر وهناك
اصرار من الطرفين على الفوز بها
اذا كان على الاوكرانيين ان ينسحبوا من
المدينه فهذا سوف يجعل الروس يسيطرون على
المدينه وهذا قد يعزز
المعنويات لدى الروس لكن المعركه لن تكون
حاسمه
فالاوكرانيون يمكن ان يشكلوا خط الدفاع
ليس بعيد عن بخموت ويوقف تقدم القوات
الروسيه انا اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين قد
انجزوا الكثير من خلال لجعل الروس يركزون
كثيرا على بخموت وهي ليست بالمدينه
الحاسمه نعم لكن لماذا هذا الاصرار على
الصمود سيد ريتشارد
واذا لم يكن الامر مكلفا كثيرا فهم يريدون
ان يحرموا الروس من السيطره اي اراضي
اوكرانيه وهم يريدون ايضا ان يجبروا الروس
على ارسال المزيد من القوات ولقد شاهدنا
النشب من منازعات بين الجيش الروسي
ومجموعه فاجنر وبالتالي
فهذا يكون في مصلحه الاوكرانيين ولكن هم
لا يريدون ان يتسببوا بها هزيمه القوات
الاوكرانيه ذاتها
شكرا جزيلا لكم مباشره من واشنطن العاصمه
وفي اول زيارته له الى اقليم دومباس منذ
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا تجول رئيس روسيا
فلاديمير بوتين في مدينه ماريوبل
الاوكرانيه وتفقد عددا من المرافق فيها
زياره يقول المراقبون انها تحمل الكثير من
الرسائل
مترجلا يتجول بوتين في ماريوبول اشهر
المدن الاوكرانيه في ذاكره العالم هنا قاد
سيارته بنفسه وهنا وقف تحت نصب اوكراني
يعلوه على مرسي وقفه برسائل ودلالات كثيره
الرئيس الروسي اختار المدينه التي تشكل
رمزا للمقاومه الاوكرانيه وقلب اوكرانيا
الصناعي واقربها الى خط نار المعارك
المستعره منذ سنه ونيف الزياره المفاجئه
تعتبر الاولى لبوتين الى المناطق التي
استولت عليها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتاتي بعد يومين فقط من اصدار
مذكره توقيف بحقه وبالتزامن مع الذكرى
التاسعه لضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرن وفقا
لوسائل اعلام الروسيه فان سيد الكرملين
زار مدرسه ومركزا للاطفال في شبه جزيره
القرش عرض يقول مراقبه انه تحدي لمن اتهمه
بقتل اطفال اوكرانيا وترحيل الاف منهم الى
روسيا
الملك تاتي زياره قبل زياره مرتقبه لشي
جين بينك حليف بوتين الابرز وفي وقت يتكتل
فيه حلفاء كييف الغربيون لدعم هجومها
المرتقب في الربيع هجوم تقول انها تريد من
خلاله استعاده اراضيها المسلوبه ما بينما
استولت عليه موسكو وما تريده كييف وقف
بوتي وقفه قال فيها الكثير وان لم يتحدث
رائد المصطفى العربيه
قلل المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي في حديث لقناه
فوقت نيوز
ان الولايات المتحده سترفض اي دعوه لوقف
اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا تخرج من اجتماع
الرئيس الروسي والصيني في موسكو
اذا خرج من هذا الاجتماع نوع من الدعوه
لوقف اطلاق النار حسنا سيكون هذا غير
مقبول ان كل ما سيفعلهم هو التصديق على
غزو روسيا حتى الان كل ما سيفعله هو اعطاء
السيد بوتين مزيدا من الوقت لاعاده
التاهيل واعاده التدريب والبقاء ومحاوله
التخطيط لهجمات متجدده في الوقت الذي
يختاره نامر وقد قلنا هذا من قبل ان السيد
الرئيس سوف يتصل ويتحدث مع الرئيس زلينسكي
ونعتقد ان الصينيين بحاجه للحصول على
المنظور الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
الى ازمه المصارف الان حيث اعلن الرئيس
السويسريه على بيرسي نبا استحواذ بنك يو
بي اس العملاق على منافسه كريدي سويس
مقابل ثلاثه مليارات فرانك سويسري ووصف
الرئيس السويسريه لاتفاق بانه احد العوامل
الهامه لتحقيق الاستقرار في سوق التمويل
الدولي لان الانهيار غير المنضبط لكريدي
سويس من شانه ان يؤدي الى عواقب لا حصر
لها لسويسرا والنظام المالي العالمي على
حد قوله بدوره قال رئيس سويس ان التطورات
الاخيره في البنوك الامريكيه ضربت البنك
في وقت غير مناسب مشيرا الى ان صفقه
الاندماج مع يو بي اس ستوفر الامانه
والاستقرار في السياق اعلن البنك المركزي
السويسري تقديم مساعده ماليه على هيئه
قروض
ب180 مليارات دولار لكل من يو بي اس
وكريدي سويس
تداعي البنوك الصغرى في الولايات المتحده
يبث الرعب في القطاع البنكي ويعيد الى
الواجهه شبح الازمه الماليه العالميه لسنه
2008 ولحد الان تقتصر الازمه على البنوك
الصغرى في البنوك الكبرى لا تزال في مامن
بسبب توافر السيوله لديها لكن هذا لم يمنع
من اثاره بعض المخاوف من احتمال حدوث ازمه
ماليه عالميه كسابقتها في 2008 السؤال
الذي يطفو على السطح الان هو الفرق بين
الازمه الحاليه والازمه الماليه العالميه
السابقه في العموم مشاهدينا هناك بعض
الاختلافات التي تجعل الازمه الماليه
الحاليه مختلفه عن ازمه سنه 2008 فخلال
الازمه الماليه العالميه الماليه الماضيه
اذن تضررت كل البنوك والمؤسسات الماليه
كبيره وصغيره اما هذه المره فالمتضرره
بشده هي البنوك الصغيره والمتوسطه كما ان
الاصلاحات التي اعقبت ازمه 2008 ادت الى
وضع قواعد لحفظ سلامه القطاع المصرفي
وهو ما استفدت منه الكثير من البنوك في
الازمه الحاليه ومن اوجه الاختلافات ايضا
التدخل السريع للدوله في الازمه الحاليه
عكس سنه 2008 حين تدخلت بعد فوات الاوامر
كما ان الوضع الاقتصادي يختلف بين
الفترتين فالنمو الاقتصادي متزايد في
الوقت الراهن بينما ارتسمت الفتره التي
سبقت ازمه 2008 بركود كبير
من باريس الباحث الاقتصادي دكتور دانيال
ملحم دكتور دانيال هل ازمه
2008 الماليه العالميه تتكرر الان
تحيه لك سيدي والمشرين الكرام تتكرر بشكل
بشكل بشكل
مباشر لا لانه هناك اختلاف جذري بين
الازمتين الاختلاف في المسبب في ازمه 2008
كان هناك مشكله الرهن العقاري
والمشتقات الماليه التي برزت عنها والتي
ادت الى انتشارها بشكل كبير بين البنوك
وبالتالي كان سقوط بنك يعني سقوط بنوك
كثيره خلفه اليوم المشكله في مكان اخر
المشكله هي تنظيميه وقانونيه واخلاقيا
نوعا ما في اوروبا وهي تعتمد على فقط
البنوك التي التي هي تحت ال250 مليار
دولار وبالتالي هناك محصوره
ماليه عالميه اخرى ما حصل لكريدي سويس
يعني صحيح انه بنكين في امريكا
بنك سيليكون فالي بنك الان كريدي سويس هل
هما في نفس الاسباب هي نفسها بمعنى انه
هذا
انهيار هذه المصارف الصغرى والمتوسطه يمكن
ان يكون عالميا
لا اليوم اليوم المشكله في امريكا ليست
منكسفه على البنوك التجاريه الكبرى على
اعتبار ان ان الرقابه من السلطات النقديه
والماليه في هذه الدول كانت كبيره على
البنوك الكبرى وبالتالي ما يحصل اليوم مع
كريدي سويس كان لا يزال عمليا هو منفصل
بشكل كبير عما حصل من سيليكون وغيرها
بالبنوك الامريكيه ولكن اليوم تصريحات
الملفت اليوم التصريح قبل قليل من خلال
اجتماع سواء كانت السلطات الماليه
والنقديه السويسريه مع مدير يو بي اس حمل
ومدير سويس حملوا نوعا ما تداعيات
المسؤوليه وبشكل كبير الى الولايات
المتحده هذا يعني ان هناك ازمه سيوله
مخفيه الى اليوم لم نراها بشكلها الكبير
وهذا وهذه التصريح نوعا ما مخيف للاصوات
لانه لا شيء لا يزال هناك شيء مخفي اليوم
نعتقد ان المشكله في كريدي سويس هي اسماء
منذ فتره طويله ولكن ادت السحوبات الكبيره
والضغوطات على باعتبارهم الاضعاف ادت الى
سحب سيوله كبيره للم
صرف الامريكيه لما يحصل بشكل مباشر هل
هناك تاثير لازمه المصارف الامريكيه علينا
في المنطقه العربيه على البنوك العربيه
وعلى البنوك الخليجيه بالذات
اليوم سيدي يعتقد ان المشكله طالما ان
المشكله لليوم لا تزال موجوده في اطارها
التنظيمي في الولايات المتحده واعتقد ان
البنوك الخليجيه ليست منكسفه بشكل كبير
على الملوك الامريكيه لان المشكله لم تطال
لم تطال الى اليوم
البنوك التجاريه بشكل رئيسي لا تزال في
بنوك الريجينال البنوك الموجوده في قطاعات
محدده وبالتالي لا يوجد انكشاف اليوم
العمليات البنكيه عاده ما تتم بين الدين
والسيوله بين البنوك وهي عاده ما تكون
انكشافاتها صغيره جدا الا اذا كان هناك
انكشافات البنوك الخليجيه الاستثماريه على
على البنوكيه السؤال الاخير وضروري كيف
ترى تاثير ازمه المصارف الامريكيه هذه على
سعر الفائده هناك خبراء من جولد يتوقعون
انه الفيدرالي الامريكي سيتجه الى تخفيض
سعر الفائده ما هي توقعاتك ماذا نتوقع في
سعر الفائده
اليوم اعتقد اليوم يجب ان ترفع سعر
الفائده ب 25 نقطه مئويه وليس 50 نقطه
مئويه اليوم الاسواق هي تحت تحت السريس
كبير جدا وبالتالي رفع 50 نقطه مئويه يؤدي
الى الى رساله قويه للاسواق وبالتالي
التقلبات حاده ويمكن ان ياخذ الفيدرالي
الاسواق او المصارف الى مكان اخر لان
المشكله اليوم هي في مشكله الوجود السندات
الخزينه بيع السندات الخزينه بخساره رفع
اسعار الفائده معناته يعني اكثر ان هناك
سندات سوف تحقق خساره اكبر اعتقد اليوم
الفيدرالي هناك حل واحد وطريق واحد امام
الفيدراليه يجب تقبل تضخم مرتفع نوعا ما
برفع قليل
الاسعار الفائده وبالتالي يكون يكافحه
التضخم من ناحيه ليس بشكل كبير مع الحصول
البنوك على شروط ماليه مقبوله وبالتالي
ضمان السيوله النقديه داخل هذه الاسواق
والا لا اذا استمر برفع الاسعار الفائده
بشكل كبير سوف تؤدي عمليا الى تجديد
الشروط المكبيه نقص السيوله ونقص السندات
التي تعتبر هي الضمانات الاوفرنيت في
اسواق بين البنوك الامريكيه وبالتالي هنا
تبرز العدوى وهنا تبرز المشكله الحقيقيه
ويمكن ان نقول ان دخلنا في ازمه مصرفيه
جديده في الولايات المتحده وسوف تنعكس على
العالم اجمع لان تطال كبر البنوك
الامريكيه وباقي البنوك التجاريه الاخرى
الباحث الاقتصادي كنت معنا من باريس
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اهالي اسطنبول
يتحضرون للزلزال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه بدا
المئات من جنود وحدات خاصه في قوه
الاحتياط التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي بداوا
بعصيان عسكري حيث لم يلتحقوا بوحداتهم
للتدريب وسط خشيه في اوساط امنيه
واستراتيجيه اسرائيليه من ان تتفاقم
الظاهره وتؤثر على وحده واداء الجيش
الاسرائيلي فيما دعى نتنياهو رئيسا اركان
وقاده الاجهزه الامنيه الى التصدي بحزم
لظاهره رفض الخدمه التي تهدد اسرائيل
في تطور غير مسبوق اسرائيليا اصبح التهديد
واقعا حيث لم يلتحق 180 طيارا حربيا
وملاحا جويا من الاحتياط والعشرات من
مشغلي المسيرات والعاملين في مجال السايبر
بوحداتهم وانضموا الى بدء 650 من مقاتلي
الوحدات الخاصه السريه من الاحتياط
حيثيانهم العسكري ايضا احتجاجا على ما بات
يسمى بمحاوله انقلاب الحكومه على نظام
القضاء في اسرائيل
وقاده الاجهزه الامنيه التصدي بحزم لرفض
الخدمه العسكريه ليس هناك مكان للاسيان
العسكري في السجال العام دوله ترغب في
البقاء لا يمكنها التسليم بظواهر كهذه
ظاهره رفض الخدمه في صفوف قوات الاحتياط
التي تشكل عماد الجيش الاسرائيلي ونصف
القوه العملانيه لسلاح الجو مرشحه للاتساع
في ظل استمرار تظاهرات الاحتجاج الحاشده
واصرار الحكومه على المضيف خطه تغيير نظام
القضاء واضعاف المحكمه العليا وسط تحضيرات
متواتره من ان تقود بوادر العنف الى حرب
اهليه
كما دوما فاننا امام امكاني تدهور امني
على عده جبهات وممنوع علينا ان تدور حرب
اخوه على جبهتنا الداخليه نتنياهو توقف
على الاقل الى ما بعد شهر رمضان
الخشيه لدى القياده العسكريه والامنيه من
ان يؤدي وصول الانقسام الى صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى انهيار موقع الاجماع شبه
الوحيد في المجتمع الاسرائيلي وان تتراجع
معنويات القتال فيما تنتظر اسرائيل تحديات
خارجيه فايران تلامس القدره النوويه
العسكريه وحزب الله اختبر اسرائيل في
عمليه مجدو في العمق وثم التخوف من اندلاع
حرب جديده على قطاع غزه وانفجار الوضع في
الضفه في شهر رمضان المغترب
بعد ان وصل الانقسام في الشارع الاسرائيلي
الى صفوف الجيش من خلال موجه رفض الخدمه
من قبل نخب قتاليه في الاحتياط يرى
مراقبون بان ذلك سيمس بجاهزيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي القتاليه في مواجهه تحديات
قريبه وبعيده وقد يؤدي الى اختبار جهات
خارجيه للواقع الاسرائيلي المازوم عسكريا
وهو يقرا ضعفا ووهنا زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه العراقيه فؤاد حسين
بغداد نجحت في التوصل الى اتفاق مثمر بين
ايران والسعوديه وعوده العلاقات بين
البلدين
ج
العراق قادم مبادره فعاله في المنطقه
بعضها انتهى بنجاح وتوجا باتفاق بين بلدين
نحن سعداء بهذا الاتفاق وعوده العلاقات
بينهما في المنطقه ما يعني خفض التوتر
وتركيز العراق على اعاده بناء اقتصاده
وامنه داخل اراضيه وفي المنطقه
[موسيقى]
ذهبنا الى اجتماع سري فقال الامريكيون
انهم اتخذوا قرارا باطاحه صدام هذا الكلام
لمسعود برزاني في حواره مع الشرق الاوسط
في السابع عشر من فبراير 2002 استقبل
مسعود برزاني وفدا من وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه استخدم الوفد عبارات اللافته من
نوع ان امريكا قررت ازاحه نظام صدام وان
الهجوم سيكون من محاور عده وان لدور
الاقليم اهميه كبيره في حسابات واشنطن
التي دعت لزيارته مسعود بارزاني بحسب ما
نقلت عنه الشرق الاوسط رد بان الاكراد
سيؤيدون اي عمليه ترمي الى قيام عراق
ديمقراطي فيدرالي تعددي كانت الاشارات
واضحه تقول الشرق الاوسط لكن برزاني كان
ينتظر سماع كلام اوضح ومن اعلى مراكز
القرع في الخامس عشر من ابريل صعد الى
طائره خاصه كانت تنتظر في مطار فرانكفورت
مسعود بارزاني يرافقه نجله مسرور وال
قيادي في الحزب والشيار زباري وزير
الخارجيه لاحقا والتام شمل الوفد الكردي
الى امريكا بوجود جلال طالباني ونجله بافل
والقيادي في حزبه برهم صالح رئيس
الجمهوريه العراقيه لاحقا
[موسيقى]
وفي ضيافه اختارت مقرها الاجهزه الامريكيه
في فرجينيا انعقد الاجتماع الحاسم حضر من
الجانب الامريكي ماك لوكلين نائب رئيس سي
اي اي والجنرال واين داوننين من الامن
القومي وريان كروكر من الخارجيه تحدث
الجانب الامريكي بلهجه تفيد بان قرارا
بالاطاحه بصدام حسين اتخذ ولا عوده عنه
استخدموا عبارات صريحه من نوع امريكا قررت
وجوب ازاحه صدام من السلطه وان الاكراد
يجب ان يحصلوا على حقوقهم كامله وامريكا
وعلى اعتماد النظام الفيدرالي في العراق
وانا امريكا لن تسمح بوجود اي تدخل خارجي
كانت لهجه الجانب الامريكي واضحه وقاطعه
وجاء الرد الكردي من القماشه نفسها تقول
الشرق الاوسط
رافق حلم اطاحه صدام مسعود البرزاني على
مدار عقود رغم الهدنات والاتفاقات وكان
يشترط للضلوع في اي خطه ضد سيده بغداد ان
يكون البديل الديمقراطيا وفدراليا تقول
الشرق الاوسط ان مسعود برزاني لم يحاول
زياره صدام في سجنه بعد القبض عليه ولم
يذهب الى جلسات محاكمته ويختصر موقفه
بالقول الشماته ليست من شيم الرجال ورغم
ما اصاب الاكراد على يد صدام يعترف مسعود
للرجل بانه كان الاجرا في البدايه في
مقاربه حق الاكراد في الحكم الذاتي
معنى من بغداد رئيس مركز التفكير السياسي
الدكتور احسان الشمري دكتور احسان اهلا بك
معنا بدايه لماذا لم يتحقق وعد الفيدراليه
في العراق بعد الاطاحه بنظام صدام حسين
شكرا على الاستضافه قد يكون هناك عده
اسباب لعدم تحقق
هذا الحلم حلم الفيدراليه اولا طبيعه
الصراع السياسي في داخل العراق وهذا
الصراع السياسي
ادى الى انعدام الثقه ما بين الاطراف حتى
المعرضه التي استلمت السلطه فيما بعد لم
تكن تثق فيما بينها هذا اولا الامر الاخر
كان ينظر الى الفيدراليه
من عامه الشعب او حتى من بعض اعضاء الطبقه
السياسيه على انه جزء من طريق تقسيم
العراق لذلك
لم يتم التفاعل مع هذا الموضوع الامر
الثالث هو طبيعه التاثيرات الخارجيه التي
مورست من قبل ايران وتركيا على اعتبارنا
منح
هذا السبب يعود الى
القرارات الخاطئه التي اتخذتها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ابتداء من ترسيخ مبدا
المحاصصه
بين القوى المعارضه التي استلمت السلطه
هذا اولا الامر الاخر القرارات المرتبطه
بحل بعض مؤسسات الدوله
الامر الثالث
ايضا
كاخطاء هو طبيعه غض الطرف عن تلك التدخلات
الخارجيه من قبل دول اقليميه في الشان
الداخلي العراقي ولذلك
نظرت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على ان
ما اقدمت عليه كان يعد خطا سيما وانها
وجدت نفسها على اقل تقدير في العام
خارج العراق وبالتالي كان هناك ضغط كبير
من قبل الراي العام الام الذي بات يتساءل
ان قرار الحرب كان قرارا خاطئا لان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تجني ما
كانت تتوقعه نعم نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور احسان الشمري كنت معنا مباشره من
بغداد ومشاهدينا انتقل بكم مباشره الان
الى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس وهذه الصور
المباشره لاستمرار الاحتجاجات ضد اصلاح
قانون التقاعد في فرنسا ورفع سن التقاعد
من 62 الى 64 عاما معنا من هناك فريدهوك
فادي انقل لنا الصوره من عندك نرى سيارات
مكافحه الشغب الفرنسيه عندك في الشارع
اهلا صهيب خرج خرج التظاهره في هذه
المنطقه
التجاريه في وسط باريس كما ترون الشرطه
حصلت المتظاهرين وهي الان تقوم بمرافقتهم
او تقسيمهم الى مجموعات وتاخذهم الى محطات
المترو لكي تؤمن خروجهم من هذه المنطقه
وتضمن عدم اعاده تجمعهم او لقائهم مع
اصدقائهم الذين قاموا
بتفريقهم طبعا في بدايه هذه التظاهره التي
خرجت بشكل عفوي ولكنه الشرطه
يعني انه تفريقهم الى مجموعات صغيره على
ما نشاهد يا فادي يعني ليس تفريقا عنيفا
نعم صهيب هم الان يفرقونهم بشكل سلمي لكن
في بدايه التظاهره جاءت الشرطه واطلقت
الغاز المسيل للدموع حتى تمكنت من محاصره
هذه المجموعات كل مجموعه حصلتها في زاويه
هذه الشوارع هنا في هذه المنطقه ضيقه جدا
فتمكنت الشرطه من محاصرتهم عبر مجموعات
صغيره كل مجموعه كانت في شارع وايضا حصلت
حالات اعتقال هناك على الاقل حتى الان ست
حالات اعتقال بحسب ما صرحت وزاره الداخليه
الان يقومون بمرافقتهم على عبر محطات
المترو ليخرجونهم من هذه المنطقه وهذه
التظاهرات هي مستمره وتخرج بشكل عشوائي
والشارع الفرنسي ملتهب منذ فتره طويله يا
فادي لنشرح قليلا للمشاهد العربي البعيد
قليلا عن الشان الفرنسي ما الذي حصل وما
الذي زاد في غضب هذا الشارع مع استخدام
الرئيس الفرنسي لماده في الدستور تخوله
اقرار الاصلاح في قانون التق اعد بدون
الذهاب الى البرلمان
نعم صهيب هذه التظاهرات اندلعت يوم الخميس
الماضي وهي مستمره منذ ذلك اليوم بسبب
قيام الحكومه بتمرير مشروع رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما من دون المرور عبر البرلمان
وتصويت النواب عليه الان هناك مذكرات لسحب
الثقه من الحكومه سيبدا التصويت عليها
ابتداء من جلسه البرلمان يوم غد الاثنين
وهذه المذكرات تحظى بدعم من قوه اقصى
اليمين بزعامه ماري لوبين وايضا من قوه
اليسار هذه المذكرات حتى الان يسعى النواب
لكي يستميل عدد من نواب الحزب الجمهوري
الذين هم غير راضيين عن هذا القانون وايضا
من المحتمل ان يصوت عليه ان كان لدي الوقت
ايضا صهيب كان هناك اخبار او هناك صور
نشرت لعدد من المقر والمكاتب التي تتبع
لنواب حزب الرئيس وايضا لرئيس الحزب
الجمهوري اريكسيوتي تمت مهاجمه هذه
المكاتب وكتب عليها شعارات مناهضه لقانون
رفع سن التقاعد لان هؤلاء النواب هم
داعمين لهذا القانون وكان هناك ادانا من
قبل وزير الداخليه طبعا هناك تاهب ابني
كبير جدا في العاصمه في محيط المقر
الحكوميه وايضا لحمايه النواب الذين
يؤيدون هذا القانون بحسب ما بحسب برقيه
ارسلها وزير الداخليه جيرالدرمان الى
مؤسسات ومديريات الامن العامه في معظم
المدن الفرنسيه نعم فادي ساكتفي معك بهذا
القدر الان يعني تبعنا معك هذه الصوره
الحيه لتفريق هذه المظاهرات المستمره
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد على الاقل ما
شاهدناه يعني الشرطه تبتسم للمتظاهرين هي
نجحت على ما يبدو في تفريقهم سلميا يعني
وتقسيمهم الى مجموعات صغيره كما تابعنا مع
هذه الاستراتيجيه التي انتهجتها الشرطه
الفرنسيه شكرا لك فادي على هذه الصوره
الحيه مباشره من باريس
[موسيقى]
اكد جوزيفوريل مفوض سياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبيه نسينا في العلاقات بين
السعوديه وايران سيساهم في استقرار
المنطقه وذلك خلال مؤتمر جمعه بوزير
الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين في
هذا
مؤخرا استئناف العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران وهذا ما قد يساهم في استقرار
المنطقه ودعونا لا ننسى بان الجوله الاولى
من المفاوضات في بغداد هي التي ادت
لمخرجات ايجابيه
[موسيقى]
مره حوالي شهر ونصف على وقوع زلزله تركيا
وسوريا المدمر ولا تزال اعراضه لم تنجلي
بعده بشكل كلي فالكثير من السكان تركيا
يعيشون حاله الرعب في ظل تداول الشائعات
عن امكانيه حدوث زلزال مدمر اخر وتحديدا
في مدينه اسطنبول مخاوف سكان مدينه
اسطنبول تتنامى شيئا فشيئا وهو ما تفعلت
معه سلطات المدينه بتكليف عشرات الفرق
المختصه بفحص المباني لتحديد مدى قدرتها
على مقاومه الزلزال ومنذ ان وقع زلزال
مطلع شهر فبراير الماضي اتصل اكثر من 140
الف شخص ببلديه اسطنبول من اجل فحص مباني
ويجول 50 فريقا من المهندسين المدينه لفحص
المباني واداء خلصوا الى ان خطرا انهيارها
مرتفع جدا فانهم يتخذون قرارا بهدمها وقد
يؤدي زلزال بقوه 7.5 درجات الى انهيار
حوالي 100 الف مبنى وذلك نقلا عن مختصين
هذا التوجس من وقوع زلزال محتمل اثر بشكل
واضح على سلوكيات جزء كبير من سكان مدينه
اسطنبول فالكثير منهم بات يبحث عن
الانتقال الى الاحياء الشماليه من المدينه
لبعدها عن مناطق الهزات المحتمل بحسب
الخبره كما ان هناك اقبالا كبيرا على
الحقائب المصممه خصيصا للزلزال وتحتوي على
مصابيح وبطانيات ومستلزمات طوارئ ومن جهه
ثانيه بعد سكان المدينه يعانون من ازمات
نفسيه تتمثل في عدم الشعور بالامان في
منازلهم بسبب الخوف من الزلازل
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه هل تؤثر مشكله
الترام في القانونيه على مساعيه للرئاسه
في 2024
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد التهم القضائيه تلاحق
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
المهدده بالاعتقال هذه المره على حد قولها
التهمه التي قد تتسبب في القبض عليه هي
تقديمه ريشا الى احدى الممثلات من اجل
التستر على علاقه عاطفيه اقامها معها
ترامب نفسه زعم انه سيجري توقيفه يوم
الثلاثاء المقبل لكن المثير هو دعوته مره
اخرى انصاره الى الاحتجاج بشكل سلمي على
حد وصفه ضد هذا الاعتقاد وفي احدى اهم
ردود الفعل حول الموضوع اعتبر نائب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ان توجيه الاتهام المحتمل
من مدعي عام مقاطعه مانهاتن الى ترامب
مقلق للغايه واشدد بانس في الوقت ذاته على
وجوب عدم التسامح مع العنف في اشاره الى
دعوه الرئيس السابق مناصريه الى الاحتجاج
كما اضاف فانس انه لا احد فوق القانون
مبديا في الوقت نفسه وثوقه من ان الرئيس
ترامب يمكنه الاعتناء بنفسه وكان فانس وهو
نائب الرئيس ترامب في فتره ولايته قد رفض
المشاركه في جهود الاخير لالغاء نتائج
انتخابات 2020 الرئاسيه من اجل البقاء في
السلطه
عن استغرابه من ان المدعي العام في منهات
يعتقد ان التوجيه الاتهام الى رئيس
الولايات المتحده السابق هو اولويه قصوى
مشيرا الى ان الامر يبدو وكانه محاكمه
مشحونه سياسيا على حد قبلها
فوجئت بفكره اتهام الرئيس السابق للولايات
المتحده في وقت كانت هناك موجه اجراميه في
مدينه نيويورك وحقيقه ان المدعي العام في
منهات يعتقد ان توجيه الاتهام الى ترامب
هو اولويه قصوى اعتقد ان الامر يخبرنا بما
نحتاجه لمعرفته اليسار اراديكالي في هذا
البلد يبدو وكان الامر محكمه مشحونه
السياسيه وهذا ما لا يحتاجه الشعب
الامريكي في ظل التحديات الحاليه والشعور
بوجود نظام عداله من مستويين في هذا البلد
اذا حدث هذا الامر الثلاثاء فيجب ان يتم
بشكل سلمي وبطريقه قانونيه
هذا وتوالت ردود فعل بخصوص امكانيه القاء
القبض على ترامب وكان رئيس مجلس نوابه
الجمهوريه كبر مكارتي قد كتب تغريده تنقل
فيها الى امريكا تواجه مره اخرى اساءه
استخداما فاضحه للسلطه متهما مدعي منهات
بالانتقام سياسيا من ترامب
اما مايكل كوهين وهو المحامي الشخصي
السابق لترامبو الذي شهد ضده في قضيه
اقتحام مبنى الكابيتون فقد شبه دعوه ترامب
للاحتجاجات بنفس صرخه المعركه التي اطلقها
قبل وقوع حادثه الهجوم على مبنى الكافي
وعدد دعواته مناصره الى الاحتجاج الى
الاذان قضيه اقتحام الكابيتول الشهيره
التي وقعت مطلع سنه 2021 حين دعا ترامب
انصره الى الاحتجال ضد ما وصفه تزويرا
للانتخابات رئاسيه التي انهزم فيها امام
الرئيس الحالي الديمقراطي
حامل كابيتول
المكان مبنى الكونجرس الامريكي التاريخ
السادس من يناير لسنه 2021
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب دعم ناصريه
لتجمع حاشد وست واشنطن والهدف والاهتجاج
على صحه نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه في عده
ولايات
المتظاهرون التجهوا الى مبنى الكابيتون
وقاموا باقتحامه
الاقتحام الديل عمليات اخلاء واغلاق
للمبنى كما اسفر عن وفاه اربعه اشخاص
واعتقالي ثمانين شخصا على خلفيه الهجوم
دعت لجنه برلمانيه الى محاكمه ترامب
بتهمه تحريض الحشود على اقتحام الكابيتول
معنا من واشنطن مراسله العربيه للتسليمان
اهلا بك معنا هل سيعتقل الرئيس السابق
من غير المؤكد حتى اللحظه اذا ما كان هناك
سيكون هناك اعتقال يوم الثلاثاء او حتى
يوم الاربعاء المقبل لا يجب ان ننسى بانه
اعتقاله اتت بناء على التسريبات اخباريه
كما ذكرها محمد ترامب الذين اكدوا بانه
ليست عبر تسريب من مكتب المدعي العام في
من هاته ربما لعدم جذب النظر لهذا المصدر
تحديدا من مكتب المدعي العام
طيب هل هناك اي بوادر لتجمع انصار الترامب
كما فعلوا في احداث اقتحام الكابيتولوريتا
في الانتخابات القادمه فوزا كاسحا ريتا
ماذا عن بقيه الاراء كيف تنظر الى هذه
القضيه واحتماليه اعتقال ترامب
هناك ردود افعال كبيره في
المجال في الخط السياسي هناك تصريح لافت
الجمهوريه المعروف في الكونغرس التي اعتبر
انه غريب هذا هذه الخطوه من قبل مدعي عامه
الذي يعتبر بانه كان له دور كبير بوصول
الرئيس ترامب الى سده الحكم في السابق
ولماذا هذا التحول المفاجئ له ولماذا
محاوله استدعاء الرئيس ترامب تحديدا بهكذا
قضيه في الوقت الذي لا تخلو منه نيويورك
ومنها تحديدا من اعمال العنف يجب التركيز
عليها
بهذه الرساله اعتبر انه هذه محاوله للنيل
سياسيا من دونالد ترامب وايضا الجو العام
صهيب في واشنطن يعتبر بانه اي خطوه بهذا
الاتجاه اي اتجاه اعتقال الرئيس ترامب
ستصب لمصلحته السياسيا وسيستخدمها
الكثير منها انتخابيا نعم في الانتخابات
2024 ريتا سليمان مراسله العربيه من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
كيف تؤثر مشكلات ترامب القانونيه على
مساعيه للرئاسه في 2024
دستوريا لم تحدد اي ماده الاتهامات او
الادانات الجنائيه التي تطال مؤهلات
الرئيس
زمنيا ربما يضطر ترامب للمثول للمحاكمه في
منتصف حملته الرئاسيه او حتى بعد
الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
جنائيات تستغرق اكثر من عام لتتحول من
مجرد اتهامات الى محاكمه اذا جرى انتخاب
ترامب لن يتمتع بسلطه العفو عن نفسه في
اتهامات موجهه بموجب قانون ولايه لكن
احاله الرئيس المنتخب للمحاكمه ستدخل
حينها حيزا قانونيا مجهولا
[موسيقى]
اظهرت لقطته فيديو غرق متحف على رصيف في
منطقه ساحليه لاقليم اورو في الاكوادور
بشكل كامل بعد انهياره خلال زلزال قوي
بلغت قوته
6.8 درجات وذكرت وسائل الاعلام المحليه ان
الموقع المعروف باسم متحف بورتو بوليفار
البحري شيد قبل اكثر من 60 عاما ويضم ما
لا يقل عن 5000 قطعه اثريه بحريه
[موسيقى]
انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز اخبارها
فاجنر تقتربوا من مركز مدينه باخموت
والجيش الاوكراني يؤكد قدرته على الدفاع
عن المدينه
اتفاق فلسطيني اسرائيلي على الحد من العنف
والتحريض ووقف الاجراءات الاحاديه من
ثلاثه الى سته اشهر
بهدف تحقيق استقرار الاسواق بنك يو بي اس
يستحوذ على كريدي سويس مقابل ثلاثه
مليارات فرنك سويسري
تهم قضائيه تلاحق الرئيس الامريكيه السابق
دونالد ترامب وتباين حول تاثيرها على
مصيره الانتخابي
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]